entscheidung von heute der
friedensnobelpreis geht an den
äthiopischen regierungschef damit manche
experten überrascht denn da waren ja
noch ganz andere heiße kandidaten im
rennen
bitte greta thonberg nein denn für den
friedensnobelpreis sind jede menge
politiker nominiert darunter mal wieder
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel habe auch
us präsident donald trump steht auf der
liste er ließ sich angeblich auf eigenen
wunsch vorschlagen alles anders geht es
ja nicht
also kein nobelpreis für greta thunberg
wenn dann wäre es wohl schlauer gewesen
die ganze freude ist for future
bewegungen auszuzeichnen wer garantiert
gar keinen preis verdient hat meiner
meinung nach ist unsere große jedenfalls
nicht für das klimaschutzgesetz dass sie
diese woche endgültig verabschiedet
haben am mittwoch keine konkrete zahl
zum beispiel um wieviel spritfressende
autos bei der kfz-steuer demnächst eurer
werden wirklich noch jede menge
lehrstellen dabei lässt unsere
umweltministerin doch kein zweifel daran
wie gefährlich dieser klimawandel ist
und was ganz konkret dagegen hilft und
deswegen müssen wir unbedingt handeln
und werden auch handeln was ist das
beste gegenmittel
das gegenmittel ist natürlich
klimaschutz klimaschutz klimaschutz
achso klimaschutz klimaschutz
klimaschutz aber wie und warum hat man
sich für ein paket entschieden dass bis
2025 kaum co2 eingespart wörtlich steht
jetzt in dem gesetz klimaneutralität
2050 wollen wir als nationales ziel
verfolgen
wahrscheinlich so wie ich das ziel hosen
größe 36 verfolgen
es fällt mir ein wollten die mich
ursprünglich mehr auf wissenschaftler
hören und da ist das zentrale element
die preise und da gibt es die meinung da
muss man sehr stark einsteigen das haben
wir uns auch wissenschaftler empfohlen
wir glauben dass man etwas langsamer
einsteigen sollte
das wiederum hat uns die wirtschaft
empfohlen tatsächlich sagen sogar
industrieverbände ein höherer co2 preis
wäre total sinnvoll zehn euro pro tonne
hat null lenkungswirkung vor allem aber
hätte man sich einen gesetz ausdenken
müssen bei dem wirklich viele bürger
etwas zurückkriegen wie in schweden und
was ich will auch deprimierender finde
wenn ein minister bei uns seine co2
ziele verfehlt hat das original 0
konsequenzen er oder sie das dann als ja
klima looser sogar erfolgreichere
kollegen an schnorren und wenn man jetzt
annimmt elektromobilität läuft super und
heizung läuft nicht so gut dann kann der
verkehrsminister zum bauminister gehen
und sagen wo man nicht ein bisschen was
tauschen york oder so willst du was
tauschen vielleicht wären wir der vogel
denn verarschen angenommen
elektromobilität läuft super ist klar
läuft sei aber nicht seit 1990 hat der
verkehrssektor null co2 eingespart 0
ich behaupte sogar diese ganze tausch
idee haben sie sich überhaupt nur für
einen minister ausgedacht als erfahrene
chefin weist du jedes team ist immer nur
so gut
wie das schwächste team mitglied denn
jeder kann irgendetwas siehste völlig
egal dass du mit mitte 40 noch in die
dritte klasse gehst du gehörst zu uns
das montessori klima kabinett wieder
recht jeder mitmachen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
aber ernst habe ich biete jede wette an
an die steuer muss demnächst ganz arm
als erster bei den kollegen fragen wolle
gase kaufe hier co2 tauschen aber
natürlich das gehört zu weit gibt es
auch gar nicht mal so wenig deutsche gar
nicht mal so wenig mitbürger denen das
mini klimapaket der groko immer noch
viel zu groß ist und von denen kommen
meist zwei argumente die einen sagen
sinngemäß ja was soll das kleine
deutschland denn alleine ausrichten da
machen wir lieber nix oder und das macht
zb die fdp gern man sagt ball
flachhalten freunde wer weiß denn welche
technischen innovationen in den nächsten
jahren noch kommen sebastian pufpaff zum
beispiel leitet das neu gegründete
christian lindner institut für sachen
die garantiert bald erfunden werden herr
pufpaff was machen sie da herr welke wir
setzen auf eine neue positive
wissenschaft kein mensch hat mehr bock
auf klima klugscheißer die uns den
ganzen tag sagen was er alles nicht geht
macht dies lasst das frisst weniger
tiere booms nicht so viele kinder in die
welt
das will keiner mehr hören du musst die
leute mitnehmen abholen und zwar nicht
mit dem bus
nein nein mit dem auto wir brauchen
nicht weniger autos wir brauchen neue
antriebe hier meine erfindung der laie
denkt ist doch ein ganz normales auto
das ist der witz wieder spanier sagt
vergessen sie benziner diesel e auto das
ist das comeback drei ford ka das
fahrzeug muss einfach nur mehrmals in
schnellen ruckartigen bewegung hin und
her gewählt werden und dann
[Musik]
[Applaus]
division no rohstoffen in diskreter
chakalaka besonders gut ich muss
fairerweise sagen das ist jetzt nur ein
modell das ist kein echtes auto nein
ja aber mein team arbeitet schon daran
das konzept auf große autos zu
übertragen
es gibt halt nur einen kleinen haken wir
brauchen unbedingt mehr leute mitreden
sie hinten
aber da arbeiten wir dran
das prinzip ist jedenfalls super
wissenschaft die spaß macht stadt dürfen
verboten
ja absolut ich hatte allerdings ein
bisschen gehofft sie arbeiten an sowas
wie geo engineering oder hier was ich
mal gelesen habe dass man so winzige
schwefelpartikel in die luft bringt die
das sonnenlicht dann reflektieren und so
die erde kühlen gibt es aber in der
brigitte gelege gehöre die ganzen
partikel hobeln ja und dann muss sie
auch noch einem flugzeug eine rakete in
der luftfahrt ist manchmal das gefühl
sie zählten auch nicht mit allen standen
nicht gut gut moment was noch dinge wir
könnten atombomben in aktive vulkane
werfen ja dann wird's richtig finster
aber auch das so gut ist müsste man mal
ausprobieren ja was ist mit der mit der
anderen idee von der man immer ließ dass
das co2 mit so gigantischen anlagen aus
der luft aus der atmosphäre ausgesaugt
wird ja das oder wir könnten auch harry
potter fragen ob das so ein co2 sauger
bräuchte man viel zu viel energie
brauchen wir so viel wie die komplette
menschheit pro jahr verbraucht wenn du
da noch ein film zusätzlich anschaltet
gut es ist eben wahrscheinlich egal aber
ich denke das sind die großen
erfindungen auf die wir alle hoffen wenn
das noch science fiction ist da müssen
wir doch früher aus der kohle raus oder
weniger fliegen ja klar müsste man aber
das macht extrem schlechte laune
moderne wissenschaft dagegen muss freude
machen jemand quer gedacht was wäre wenn
wir menschen gar nicht mehr auto fahren
sondern unsere hunde
er macht das sehr gut aber man
zurückgefragt spart das den co2 sieht
super lustig aus und wenn schon
weltuntergang dann doch wenigstens ein
bisschen spaß in den backen oder
doch sicherlich zu hoch
und dann meine damen und herren gab es
parallel in den letzten tagen auch noch
eine relativ kontroverse diskussion über
die demos von extinction rebellion an
sicher gehört das ist die erwachsene
variante von friday is for future weil
die in berlin straßen und plätze
blockiert haben was staus in berlin
unvorstellbar und was ich ja immer gut
finde wenn bild und ton in einem beitrag
wie hier im folgenden optimal
zusammenpassen
ich habe mit vielen gesprochen und da
kamen ganz erstaunliche dinge zutage zum
beispiel letzte sogar umarmungen gegeben
haben soll
zwischen demonstranten und polizisten
die berühmte berliner umarmung meine
damen und herren tatsächlich tatsächlich
ist es aber überwiegend friedlich
geblieben extinction rebellion warnt vor
dem sterben ganzer ökosysteme
denen geht es also auch um artenschutz
herzlich willkommen zu unserer neuen
rubrik
ein etwas anderer meinung
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nur sagen ich finde ja toll die neue
bewegung ich finde toll dass die nervt
demos müssen nerven aber die sagen ja
klimaschutz weil pflanzen und tiere
aussterben ich meine wen soll das sie
interessieren also mein bisher war das
argument für den klimaschutz
die menschheit stirbt aus wenn wir so
weitermachen und die reaktion der
menschheit war ja wie ich schau mal das
auto stehen lassen wenn meine frau fährt
ja und dem wird gesagt hier aber die
arten sterben aus und dann sollen die
reagieren mit was die galapagos
schildkröte stirbt aus wo ist die
nächste autobahn die ich umsetzen kann
glaube ich nicht ich glaube die
menschheit muss für klimaschutz erst mal
wieder zusammen kommen und wie macht man
das ich glaube in dem man tiere
ausgrenzt
warum sind wenn ich einfach alle gegen
tiere also nicht deutschland den
deutschen sondern der planet den
menschen
foto rassismus ohne opfer das einzige
problem ist es gibt leute die mögen
tiere die verhindern den weltfrieden
also tief habe noch nie verstanden als
ich meine es jetzt gar nicht so dass die
tiere nicht mag oder so wirklich nicht
sind einfach egal alles irgendwie immer
so wir menschen machen unser ding
die tiere machen ihr tier degen ab und
zu gibt's leberwurst tierliebhaber ich
verstehe das nicht das sind leute die
gucken auch gerne tierfilme warum denn
ich denke mal habt ihr alles
interessante in eurem leben schon
gemacht dass ihr euch denkt mir jetzt
noch drei stunden doku über die
bachstelzen kann nicht sterben
tierfilme ich habe es nie verstanden
sagte der sprecher
meine damen und herren hier sehen sie
das und dann muss es jemanden geben der
vor dem fernseher sitzt und sagt mensch
habe ich noch gedacht da bleibe ich dran
und da sagte der sprecher das ist nur
ein herzlich zu 97 prozent der schocker
palme und dann gibt's offenbar menschen
die sagen wenn ich 97 prozent hast du
das gehört renate
also bei 80 prozent weiter geschaltet
aber 97 prozent gibt mir mehr fun fact
übers klug sagte der sprecher am meisten
auf den lateinischen namen von den
viechern das gewöhnliche genug ist genug
ursus mir egal
alles was liegt ist ein vogel alles was
schwimmt es sind fisch alles anderes
gefährt fertig ich verstehe einfach
nicht dass sind auch leute gerne in zoos
gehen warum die sind doch da eingesperrt
wenn ich menschen mag ich gerne im knast
ich möchte gleich alle tiere abwerten
indem ich sage menschen sind die
klügsten lebewesen des planeten fühlt
sich doch gut an
ja klar ist aber es auch um ganz ohne
opfer da kommt ja keine kugeln deckung
beschwert ich gesagt nee ich bin aber
auch ganz schön pfiffig rede dann wird
gesagt dem planeten würde es so viel
besser gehen wenn kein mensch darauf
leben würde ist doch quatsch
ohne den menschen gibt es da gar kein
naturschutz man nachdenken
naturschutz da ist sich der herr fuchs
wieder zu fein zu
und ständig setzen wir uns für bedrohte
tierarten ein
wann kommt denn mal was zurück dann sehe
ich denn mal die ersten pinguine in der
fußgängerzone
sie können sich doch mal von bedrohte
menschen haben einsetzen was er sich
katholiken aber sozialdemokraten also
zur versöhnung kann man vielleicht sagen
der mensch ist das klügste lebewesen des
planeten aber das ist noch nichts worauf
man sich ausruhen kann also ich meinen
wir treten gegen lebewesen an die sich
zur begrüßung abo riechen
da hat man es leicht theora noch hans de
schreibt über die heute show ihr seid
die richtigen links [ __ ] besonders
welke die stradivari unter den
arschgeigen bei euch smileys
freudentränen freudentränen freundin
trennen freund rennkurs mit herz vielen
dank für ihr freundliches feedback für
ein exklusives geigensolo von oliver
welke
abonnieren sie den kanal